hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream wir freuen uns sehr dass ihr bei
uns seid bei uns geht es heute um das
hier bei uns geht es um die Frage so
isoliert ist Russland
denn US-Präsident Joe Biden und Chinas
Staatschef hi Jinping die haben sich
heute einen Tag vor dem Start des G20
Gipfels auf Bali zusammen persönlich
getroffen und sie haben sich angenäht
daraus ergibt sich die Frage wendet sich
China von Russland jetzt ab wir haben
hier die Bilder vom ersten Handshake vom
ersten Aufeinandertreffen auch die
Gesichtsausdrücke sind wir da ein
Lächeln im Gesicht von hier auch Joe
Biden haben wir dort im Bild wir wollen
dieser Frage ob sich China von Russland
abwendet und den Hintergrund des
Treffens natürlich auf den Grund gehen
gemeinsam mit euch aber auch mit unserem
USA Korrespondenten und Washington
Studio Leiter Elma teven der das Treffen
für uns vor Ort begleitet mit Christian
Mölling Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik in
Berlin und mit für Bega aus dem Studium
Moskau von uns dort schalten wir auch
gleich als erstes hin aber natürlich
auch gerne mit Euch und mit euren Fragen
stellt die gerne direkt in die Chats
oder per Mailadresse kommt ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
so unser erster Blick nach Russland für
Bega ist da in Moskau für morgen startet
der G20-Gipfel auf Bali es ist das
Treffen der 19 größten Industrie- und
Schwellenländer mit der EU auch Russland
gehört dazu wird teilnehmen in Person
von Außenminister lavroff heißt also
auch im Klartext während sich hi und
beiden da gerade treffen ist einer nicht
dabei Wladimir Putin russlands Präsident
warum genau ist er da nicht vor Ort
ja die offizielle Erklärung die Putins
Pressesprecher dazu abgegeben hat die
lautet dass die derzeitige Situation es
erforderlich mache dass der Präsident
sich in der Russischen Föderation
aufhaltet was genau das sein soll das
hat pescof nicht ausgeführt es scheint
jedenfalls nicht die militärische
spezialoperation zu sein denn mit der
hat sich Präsident Putin in den letzten
Tagen ausdrücklich nicht beschäftigt es
ist so dass Russland ganz sicher in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten abgeklopft
hat ob auf Bali etwas zu holen sein
könnte oder ob eine große Blamage Tod ob
eben die Isolation die internationale
Isolation auf großer Bühne zu deutlich
werden würde ob zu viele Staaten zu
deutlich zum Ausbruch bringen werden
dass sie gegen die russische Politik
gegen die russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine sind und das hat sich
abgezeichnet China aber auch Indien zum
Beispiel haben schon im Vorfeld immer
mal wieder durchblicken lassen dass sie
nicht ganz fest an der Seite Russlands
stehen was das angeht und so hat
Präsident Putin jetzt eben seinen
Außenminister geschickt bleibt noch so
ein bisschen die Anschlussfrage anders
warum warum agiert Putin so dass er sich
so wie jetzt bei dem G20-Gipfel auch
generell international auf der Bühne
selten präsentiert es ist ja dann auch
so eine selbstausgewählte Isolation oder
ich denke es ist so dass er aus dieser
Isolation auch nicht wirklich rauskäme
wenn er sich auf so einen Gipfeltreffen
begibt er weiß sehr genau dass seine
Politik das vor allem seinen Angriff auf
die Ukraine auf viel
Gegenwehr stößt das hat er zum Beispiel
auch gemerkt bei verschiedenen un
Resolutionen wo nur ganz wenige Länder
mit Russland gestimmt haben oder sich
enthalten haben also das Russland
international isoliert ist dass die
allermeisten Länder der
Staatengemeinschaft den russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine verurteilen das
ist Wladimir Putin auch klar ohne dass
er sich dem persönlich aussetzen muss
sein Vertreter ist lavrov Außenminister
Russlands es gab heute Aufregung um
ihnen Berichte dass er ins Krankenhaus
eingeliefert worden sein soll dass
Dementi aus Moskau das kamen sofort und
auch ein Video von der Sprecherin des
russischen Außenministeriums dass sie
über telegram geteilt hat als Beweis
eben dass er nicht ins Krankenhaus
eingeliefert sein soll dass es ihm gut
gehe er hat das auch als Attacke gegen
westliche Journalisten genutzt und
gesagt sie sollen richtig berichten und
nicht falsche Nachrichten verbreiten für
erklär uns auf erste Frage endlich war
lavrov heute im Krankenhaus ja oder nein
tja das kann ich so genau natürlich auch
nicht sagen also Außenminister laborov
ist 72 Jahre alt der ist seit 18 Jahren
im Amt und er hat den asian-gipfel in
den Knochen stecken er ist direkt aus
Kambodscha nach Bali gereist kann schon
sein dass er gesundheitlich ein bisschen
angeschlagen war aber ja die russische
Seite die gibt eben ein offizielles
Dementi raus und sagt mit der Gesundheit
des Außenministers darum ist es sei es
gut bestellt gehen wir auf die
inhaltlichen Punkte ein in dem Video
kündigt lavrov auch anders Russland die
G20 Abschlusserklärung annehmen will das
soweit da detailsikern dann am späten
Nachmittag durch die Agentur dpa beruht
beruft sich auf Information eines
westlichen Diplomaten offenbar sei
Russland bereit zu akzeptieren dass in
der Abschlusserklärung des G20-Gipfels
eine Passage zur Verurteilung des
Krieges aufgenommen wird dabei werden
der russische Angriff auch ganz klar als
das bezeichnet was es ist als Krieg
auf den ersten Blick für behört sich das
wie ein Zurückweichen an ist es das aber
auch
also ich werde sehr vorsichtig zum einen
ist es so dass die Abschlusserklärung ja
eben noch nicht unterschrieben ist und
auch noch nicht ganz klar ist was dann
da drin stehen soll mag sein dass
Russland sich im Moment noch ausrechnet
die Chance dass man vielleicht um diese
Formulierung irgendwie herumkommt aber
selbst wenn Russland sich am Ende
durchregent und diese Abschlusserklärung
unterzeichnet und wenn da drin dann
tatsächlich steht dass es einen Krieg in
der Ukraine gibt dann heißt das noch
lange nicht dass Russland damit
eingesteht dass es selbst der Aggressor
in der Ukraine ist Russland sieht sich
durchaus auch in einem Krieg aber eben
in einem Krieg mit dem Westen in einem
Krieg mit den USA vor allem mit der NATO
und Russland sagt immer wieder die
Ukraine sei da nur ein Stellvertreter
und versucht ja so auch immer wieder
seinen Angriff eben zu rechtfertigen
also ich glaube
wir werden da wahrscheinlich sehen dass
da sehr verschiedene Interpretationen
auf dem Markt sein werden über das
Papier das da am Ende unterschrieben
wird
vergangene Woche blicken wir auf die
Situation im Land und auch auf die
Situation im Krieg vergangene Woche die
Meldung von der Rückeroberung durch die
Ukraine große Jubelbilder große Image
Emotionen auf Seiten der Ukraine wie ist
diese Rückeroberung in Russland
angekommen sowohl in der Bevölkerung als
auch innenpolitisch
in der Bevölkerung muss man sagen da
findet das nicht so wahnsinnig viel
Niederschlag es ist schon so dass die
Erzählung die das Staatsfernsehen hier
verbreitet bei ganz vielen Menschen
verfängt und da heißt es ja nun mal dass
dieser Rückzug der wird da auch gar
nicht Rückzug genannt sondern der wird
rekrupierung genannt und der soll
angeblich stattgefunden haben um die
Leben von russischen Soldaten zu
schützen also da wird eine Art
Fürsorgepflicht dargestellt und das
scheint tatsächlich bei vielen Russinnen
und Russen zu verfangen andere
interessieren sich ehrlich gesagt auch
einfach gar nicht so sonderlich für das
was da in der Ukraine passiert
innenpolitisch ist es so dass man
durchaus kritische Stimmen hier hört
dass insgesamt die Militärführung
kritisiert wird dass die schlechte
Ausstattung die schlechte Planung und so
weiter und so fort durchaus auch mit
harschen Worten angegangen wird aber das
ist eine Kritik die eben immer im
Verteidigungsministerium sozusagen
hängen bleibt also die erreicht nicht
den Präsidenten selbst der ist irgendwie
da immun gegen und das obwohl er ja den
Angriff auf die Ukraine wohl gestartet
hat und auch der Oberbefehlshaber der
russischen Truppen ist soweit die
Eindrücke aus Russland die Perspektive
der Ukraine da ist Präsident selensky in
die Gebiete gefahren nach der
Rückeroberung hat sie besucht und er hat
auch dort davon gesprochen dass es
womöglich der Anfang des Ende des
Krieges ist und er hat dann auch noch
diese Aussage hier getroffen
also das hört man wir sind bereit für
Frieden aber für unseren Frieden in
unserem Land für was sagt Moskau dazu
Moskau gibt sich auch eigentlich seit
Beginn dieser sogenannten militärischen
spezialoperation immer
gesprächsbereit allerdings sind die
Forderungen die Moskau überhaupt stellt
um zu diesem Gesprächen bereit zu sein
so
solche Art dass die Ukraine sie
eigentlich nicht akzeptieren kann also
am Anfang hieß es zum Beispiel die
Ukraine müsse Enden nazifiziert werden
das Regime müsste ausgetauscht werden
und das obwohl es sich in Kiew wir haben
eine demokratisch gewählte Regierung
handelt jetzt ist es vermutlich so dass
Kiew aus russischer Sicht akzeptieren
müsste dass die vier kürzlich
annektierten Gebiete also Herr Sonne
saporesia donieck und auch nuhanski dass
die russische Territorium sein sollen
auch das ist natürlich für die Ukraine
überhaupt nicht gangbar
danke schön Vögel gar aus Moskau mit dem
ersten Blick hier bei ZDF heute live bei
uns aus Russland herzlichen dank dir
ja so isoliert ist Russland nach heute
wir blicken jetzt auf das Treffen von
China Staatsoberhaupt hier und
US-Präsident beiden und Arne Gellinek
hat da die Eindrücke vom ersten Treffen
der beiden seit fünf Jahren in
widersprüchlichen Setting für uns dabei
die gipfelkulisse auf der Ferieninsel
Bali maximal traumhaft der Zustand der
G20 des Clubs der 20 wichtigsten
Industrie- und Schwellenländer maximal
kompliziert noch bevor der Gipfel morgen
losgeht treffen sich der amerikanische
und der chinesische Präsident um
Klartext zu reden das erste Gespräch von
Angesicht zu Angesicht seit fünf Jahren
in denen sich die Rivalität zwischen den
USA und China weiter zuspitzte
wir müssen unseren Beziehungen jetzt
eine Richtung nach vorn geben und sie
weiterentwickeln drei Stunden setzen die
beiden zusammen und besprechen die
jeweiligen roten Linien das China
aufrüstet und Taiwan bedroht dass die
USA Chinas Wirtschaft mit Strafzöllen
und Exportkontrollen hemmen und vor
allem das China zusammen mit Russland
eine anti-westliche allianzformt
immerhin hier eine kleine Bewegung
wir haben über die russische Aggression
gegen die Ukraine gesprochen und waren
uns einig dass die Drohung Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen absolut inakzeptabel ist
dieser Satz soll auch in der
Abschlusserklärung des Gipfels
Auftauchen der russische Außenminister
Sergej lavroff ist ebenfalls schon da
nach offenbar kurzem
Krankenhausaufenthalt auf Bali
verbreitet das russische
Außenministerium eilig Bilder des
Ministers in Shorts und T-Shirt auch
ohne putin ist die Haltung der
russischen Delegation klar jede Kritik
am ukrainekrieg soll abgewehrt werden
die Frage vor der Traumkulisse von Bali
ist also ob es dem anti-westlichen Lager
gelingt den G20 Club weiter zu spalten
tja sprechen wir darüber mit MRT wir
sind vor Ort USA Korrespondent und
Washington Studioleiter hallo nach Bali
grüße Sie
hallo nach Deutschland schönen Abend
also Herr tewesen Joe Biden sagt hier
habe zugestimmt dass es niemals zu einem
nuklearen Krieg mit Atombomben kommen
darf es ist ja als klares Statement
gegen die russischen Drohungen zu
verstehen ist das jetzt dieser
gemeinsame Schulterschluss gegen
Russland
ja man kann zumindest das als ein klein
wenig mehr Isolierung von Russland
betrachten und damit haben wir
eigentlich nicht gerechnet der eine Satz
ist ja der dass man sagt Atomwaffen
dürfen und sollen nicht eingesetzt
werden das ist etwas was man gemeinsam
sogar noch vor wenigen Monaten in einer
Erklärung unterschrieben hat viele
Staaten der Welt haben sich diese
Erklärung angeschlossen Anfang des
Jahres aber jetzt kommt eben der Satz
dazu man darf auch nicht mit dem Einsatz
von Atomwaffen drohen und das ist eben
oder kann eben als ein sehr klares
Signal an Moskau verstanden werden und
ich glaube es hat sich in den letzten
Tagen schon so ein bisschen angebahnt
dass China nicht mehr ganz so an der
Seite von Putin steht auch wenn man vor
ein paar Tagen noch gesagt hat man sei
ganz dicht bei seinem Bündnispartner hat
sich beim asian-gipfel vor ein paar
Tagen in Kambodscha schon abgezeichnet
dass man auf die Souveränität von
Staaten pochen will und dass man eben
auch der Meinung ist mit Atomwaffen
droht man nicht das ist jetzt ganz
offenbar miteinander auch so besprochen
worden und das ist eben ein klares
Signal an ja und auch eine klare
Bewegung wie sie sagen weg von Russland
bleiben wir bei diesem Aspekt wir haben
das gerade auch schon von für Begehren
Moskau gehört wir haben darüber
gesprochen über die Informationen rund
um die Abschlusserklärung die
Informationen auf die sich die dpa
beruft die sagen dass diese möglichen
Zustimmungen auch als mögliches weiteres
Zeichen gedeutet werden könnten das eben
Russland nicht mehr auf China als sein
Verbündeten zählen kann was sind da ihre
Informationen
ja ich würde so weit noch nicht gehen
aber es sind Anzeichen des China ein
bisschen schon abrückt von Russland und
tatsächlich hören auch wir aus
Diplomatenkreisen dass man sich auf eine
Formulierung verständigt hat für die
Abschlusserklärung von der übrigens
niemand erwartet hat dass es eine gibt
eine gemeinsame Erklärung aber offenbar
hat man einen Text erarbeitet und sich
auch verständigt auf einen Satz ich lese
den mal vor es darf heutzutage keinen
Krieg mehr geben ich sag mal das ist
nicht ganz konkret auf den Ukraine Krieg
bezogen es steht jedenfalls da nicht
Wort für Wort irgendwo drin aber es ist
ein sehr klares Signal dass damit
natürlich auch der Ukraine kriegt
gemeint ist und das entspricht etwa dem
was man in der letzten Resolution der
Vereinten Nationen auch drin stehen
hatte und es muss wohl hinter den
Kulissen so hören wie er Gespräche
darüber gegeben haben ob dieser Satz in
die Abschlusserklärung reinkommt und
ganz offenbar hat China keine Anstalten
gemacht der russischen Lesart des ganzen
irgendwie beizuspringen und Russland
wird am Ende möglicherweise sogar diesen
Satz weil allgemein genug ist mittragen
weil Russland gemerkt hat dass selbst
China nicht bereit ist sie zu
unterstützen wenn das tatsächlich so
käme ich glaube das ist ein klares
Signal ist aber übrigens auch nicht so
ganz überraschend weil China hat sich in
den letzten Monaten ja seit Kriegsbeginn
auch geweigert aktiv Russland zu helfen
zum Beispiel durch Munition oder durch
Waffen oder ähnliches man hält sich ein
bisschen zurück und dieses scheint ein
Signal zu sein dass China ist wichtiger
ist dass der Ukraine Krieg möglichst
weit beendet wird weil er natürlich die
Weltwirtschaft massiv belastet und
darunter leidet eben auch China danke
Ihnen für diese Einordnung rund um diese
Information blicken wir auf das Treffen
vor Ort sie haben das verfolgt und unter
anderem können wir uns ein Tweet von
ihnen anschauen den sie abgesetzt haben
den sehen wir hier movers und Shakers
beiden trifft hi auch da sehen wir noch
mal das erste Aufeinandertreffen die
erste Begrüßung Hände schütteln ein
Lachen in die Kamera hätte wissen was
lesen Sie aus diesen Bildern und
Emotionen angezeigt werden
ja ich glaube das ist einfach recht
banal den beiden ist wichtiger dass man
wirtschaftlich vorankommt weil man sich
in einem sehr sehr scharfen Wettbewerb
sieht das hat Joe Biden auch sehr klar
gesagt und werde einen energischen
Wettbewerb gegen China führen und damit
meinte nicht nur wirtschaftlich sondern
auch politisch die USA sehen sich ja in
dem Wettbewerb mit China auch in einem
Wettbewerb mit dem anderen System
nämlich dem Autoritarismus Amerika auf
der Seite der Demokratien und Joe Biden
hat in den vergangenen Wochen und
Monaten Bündnisse geschmiedet die ein
klares Signal an China senden das eben
die USA auch eng wirtschaftlich und
militärisch mit Bündnispartnern
zusammenarbeiten und China sich
isolieren könnte wenn es eben weiter
einen sehr scharfen Kurs gegenüber
Taiwan fährt nun hat man heute im Grunde
genommen dann schlicht und ergreifen
sich mal die Meinung gesagt man hat
Tacheles gesprochen aber am Ende kann
man zu dem Schluss man ist sich einig
dass man sich uneins ist in so fragen
wie Taiwan insofern wie menschenre oder
Handelsbarrieren und wenn man sich das
mal klar gesagt hat dann erzeugt das
auch ein Stück weit ich sag mal
Stabilisierung man weiß was man von dem
anderen zu halten hat und das macht den
Weg frei um zu schauen wo kann man
vielleicht doch ein bisschen weiter
kommen und so hat man auch beschlossen
dass man Arbeitsgruppen einsetzt auf
kabinettsebene und die werden sich um
die großen Probleme der Zeit kümmern
Klimawandel Lieferketten Engpässe
Nahrungsmittelkrise Schuldenkrise und
ähnliches und das erstmal ein gutes
Zeichen das offenbar die USA und China
ein großes Interesse haben dass ich sag
mal dieser Wettbewerb manche nennen es
auch Rivalität mit einem drohenden
Kalten Krieg dass man den managen will
damit es eben nicht zu einer Eskalation
kommt sie sprechen es an Tacheles kann
eigentlich nur dann gesprochen werden
wenn die Kommunikationskanäle dafür
bereitet sind das Verhältnis der beiden
ist ja interessant Joe Biden er sagt
immer dass also er programmiert ist dass
er einer derjenigen ist der Chi so gut
kennt wie wie kaum jemand anderes er
sagt auch dass sie sich schon erkennen
in vorherigen Ämtern er sagt auch dass
sie schon damals immer offene
Diskussionen gepflegt haben also eben
genau wie sie es jetzt sagen Tacheles
gesprochen haben wie gut ist denn dieses
Verhältnis zwischen den beiden
ja es ist natürlich schon so dass sie
zum Beispiel sich 2011 getroffen haben
da waren beide eben Vizepräsidenten und
da kam Joe Biden zurück hat bei Meeting
gesagt der ist im Grunde am straight
forward also klar und deutlich und
gleichzeitig auch verlässlich und man
kann mit dem zusammenarbeiten hat aber
dann noch nach seiner Rückkehr gesagt
der wird uns noch eine Menge Probleme
bereiten und so ist es dann gekommen im
Jahr 2015 beispielsweise als nämlich Joe
Biden Vizepräsident und Barack Obama
Präsident war da war ich in Ping in
Washington und hat im Grunde genommen
sehr klare Ansagen in Richtung
Indopazifik gemacht hat gesagt der
Indopazifik ist ein Gebiet das müssen
wir uns aufteilen hat also einen
Anspruch erhoben einen Machtanspruch in
dieser Region und hat dafür auch Inseln
in Anspruch genommen die nach
internationalem Seerecht gar nicht China
gehören und da hat China mittlerweile
Militärbasen drauf gebaut also Joe Biden
weiß sehr genau dass man China sehr sehr
ern muss insbesondere Regin Peng und
deswegen ist seine Linie vom ersten Tag
gewesen knallharte Offenheit in der
Hoffnung dass wenn man sich das eben
klar ausspricht dass man den anderen ich
sag mal ein bisschen berechenbarer macht
das gilt für beide Seiten und dass man
im Zweifel wenn es mal zu einem Konflikt
kommen könnte lieber direkt zum Telefon
greift um ich sag's mal sehr salopp die
Kuh auch ganz schnell wieder vom Eis zu
bekommen sie haben einen Knackpunkt auch
gerade schon angesprochen und das ist
das Thema Wirtschaft und Handel eben
auch aus diesem Grund gelten ja die
Beziehungen vor dem Treffen so schlecht
wie seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr die USA
will verhindern dass China an ihn als
Wirtschaftsmacht vorbei zieht Frage an
Sie wie genau versucht beiden da
vielleicht auch heute und in den
weiteren verlaufen des Tages
entgegenzuwirken und andere Frage lässt
sich Peking lässt sich jeder von
überhaupt bremsen
ja also Joe Biden hat im Grunde genommen
nicht als erster sondern vor ihm schon
Donald Trump und davor sogar Barack
Obama angefangen eine Trennung der
chinesischen und amerikanischen
Wirtschaft in kritischen Bereichen
herbeizuführen das heißt Investitionen
aus China in den USA in kritische
Infrastruktur zu verhindern teilweise
sogar die chinesischen Firmen
auszuzahlen und sie wieder rauszuwerfen
aus amerikanischen Firmen weil man eben
der Meinung ist man muss unabhängig sein
von China man beginnt damit in den USA
massiv auch eigene Ressourcen zu fördern
Seltene Erden Lithium man baut selber
jetzt Batterien das war bisher so dass
China das einzige Land der Erde war dass
vom Rohstoff bis zur fertigen Batterie
die komplette Herstellungskette
beherrschte das wollen die USA jetzt
auch und sie suchen sich Verbündete rund
um den Erdball Erdball bieten Ihnen auch
wirtschaftliche und militärische
Zusammenarbeit an das hat Joe Biden
jetzt gerade wieder beim asian-gipfel
getan und auch vor wenigen Monaten ein
indopazifisches Wirtschaftsforum
gegründet also man macht auch massive
wirtschaftskonkurrenz gegenüber China
und das was China ein Stück weit auch
als Kriegserklärung ansieht ist eine
handelsbeschränkung die Joe Biden erst
vor wenigen Wochen in Kraft gesetzt hat
da geht es darum dass neueste
Hochtechnologie im Mikrochip und
Halbleiterbereich auf keinen Fall in die
Hände Chinas gelangen soll und das gilt
nicht nur für amerikanische Firmen
sondern alle Firmen rund um den Erdball
die in irgendeiner Weise in ihren
Halbleitern und Mikrochips
amerikanisches Know-how verarbeitet
haben auch die müssen mit Sanktionen
rechnen wenn sie an China liefern der
Hintergrund ist dass ein Teil dieser
Technologie auch in neueste
Waffensysteme in China eingebaut wird
das hat man sich heute auch sehr klar
gesagt und skigebling hat sehr klar
gesagt das kann er nicht akzeptieren
weil damit Chinas Wirtschaft ausgebremst
wird wenn es keinen Zugang zu dieser
Hochtechnologie hat also man weiß was
man voneinander zu halten hat und das
gibt beiden im Grunde genommen auch ein
Stück einen Hebel in die Hand vielleicht
eben über diese Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
auch Kompromisse in anderen Bereichen zu
erreichen sehr viele Details zwei Stück
Herr Thesen noch kurz zum Schluss ein
wichtiges und eine weitere diffizile
Verstrickung der Taiwan Konflikt China
betrachtet ja die demokratisch regierte
Insel als eigenes Staatsgebiet die USA
sie treten auch als Schutzmacht auf
gegenüber Taiwan und sie sagen und
warnen China vom militärischen
Eingriffen wurde über dieses Thema heute
auch gesprochen
ja und zwar sehr klar von beiden
seitenping hat gesagt dass eine interne
Angelegenheit das entscheidet alleine
China und damit eben auch Taiwan als
Teil von China so sieht er das
eigentlich will er auch das hat er in
der Vergangenheit angekündigt bis zum
Jahr 2040 49 spätestens das Taiwan
gewissermaßen wieder heimgeholt wird in
das Festland in das chinesische Festland
und der amerikanische präsent hat heute
noch mal sehr klar gesagt es bleibt zwar
bei der einen China-Politik aber die
besagt eben dass die Völker beiderseits
der Straße von Taiwan das Recht haben
über ihre Zukunft zu entscheiden das
heißt auch die Menschen in Taiwan
müssten zustimmen wenn sie wieder Teil
Chinas werden wollten das ist nirgendwo
in Sicht und deswegen hat man das jetzt
zwar mal klar ausgesprochen und damit
auch klar gemacht dass wenn einer die
rote Linie überschreitet dass es zu
neuen militärischen Konfrontation kommen
würde und wenn man das jetzt so klar hat
heißt das vielleicht dass keiner es
riskiert weil wichtig wirtschaftliche
Gründe dem entgegenstehen und auf diese
Weise hat man auch durch diese klaren
Aussagen heute vielleicht die Situation
vielleicht sage ich stabilisiert und
ganz kurz zum Schluss sie sind vor Ort
in Bali heute sozusagen einen Tag davor
was erwarten sie von den kommenden Tagen
von diesem G20-Gipfel auf Bali
ja es gibt ja Probleme genug und am
morgigen Tag will man sich insbesondere
mit den
nahrungsmittelengpässen befassen und mit
den energieenpässen in dieser Welt aber
auch den gemeinsamen Kampf gegen
Pandemien gegen Bedrohungen für die
Gesundheit der Menschheit will man
angehen da wird zur Erklärungen geben da
wird es Initiativen geben aber allen ist
klar der große Elefant im Raum das ist
im Grunde der Ukraine Krieg die
Weltwirtschaft und um die haben alle die
größte Sorge die kann erst dann wieder
richtig in die Gänge kommen wenn dieser
Krieg beendet wird und deswegen ist so
wichtig dass vielleicht in dieser
Abschlusserklärung dann eben auch klare
Worte drin stehen sagt MRT wissen er
verfolgt für uns die Reise vor Ort auf
Bali zum G20-Gipfel herzlichen Dank für
ihre Einschätzungen und ersten Eindrücke
von vor Ort dankeschön
und wir gehen direkt weiter zu Christian
möhling Politikwissenschaftler und
Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik in
Berlin und auch Leiter des Programms
Sicherheit und Verteidigung schön guten
Abend herrling
hallo gelernteile hemmeling ich möchte
mit einer user-frage einsteigen und die
knüpft an die Diskussion gerade an
Musculus latissimus dorsi so viel Zeit
muss sein fragt bei Youtube was könnte
es hier jeden Ping denn für Vorteile
bringen sich gegen Putin zu wenden
eben schon den Beitrag an von MRT werden
auch das
es für China um das schnelle Ende des
Konfliktes geht weil es zurzeit die
Wirtschaft behindert und das ist
natürlich für China einen ein wichtiger
Faktor der da ist man macht sich
gleichzeitig aber ich will nicht sagen
unverzichtbar aber man macht sich
zumindest
man macht es sich einfach sich zwischen
Moskau und die USA zum Beispiel zu
stellen und zu zeigen guck mal wir
können auch kooperieren also man wird
auf einmal wieder ein interessanter
Kooperationspartner aus Sicht Pekings
muss ich da auch der Rest der Welt wenn
man tatsächlich
Moskau für einen Zeit lang beiseite
schieben kann
mr teven hat auch gesagt dass er das
Treffen und auch die Inhalte als erste
Bewegung von China auch weg von Russland
sieht hin zum Westen hin zu den USA bei
dem Treffen wie würden sie das bewerten
das mag so sein da macht aber sicherlich
eine Schwalbe noch keinen Sommer also
das soll heißen dass ich hier jetzt
insgesamt die Politik zwischen Peking
und Moskau komplett verschiebt auf Dauer
da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher
ich glaube da hängt es sehr stark davon
ab welche Vorteile mittelfristig China
noch in so einer Perspektive in so einer
in so einer Verbindung sieht es bedeutet
ja auch das sehen wir heute mal auf das
zu verschieben gesagt habe dass die
Schwäche moskau ist und diese
Abhängigkeit dazu führt dass Peking
international wichtiger wird viele haben
akzeptiert dass Peking eine Rolle in
diesem Konflikt spielt und diese Rolle
nutzt es aus das heißt also dieser
Isolierung Russlands hilft China im
Grunde genommen mit dieser Situation
warum sollte man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
darauf verzichten aber ich glaube dass
man das der taktisch spielen wird
also auch das war ja die die
Einschätzung und Einordnung ein kleiner
anfänglicher Schritt aber das muss
natürlich weiter beobachtet werden
lassen sie uns Herr Müller in gemeinsam
auf folgende Bilder hier schauen vom 16
September das ist keine zwei Monate her
da ist Putin zu Gast auf dem Gipfel der
shanghai-organisation für Zusammenarbeit
in Usbekistan und er war für das Treffen
vor allem ja eine Möglichkeit gesehen
Partnerschaften zu vertiefen vor zwei
Monaten allen voran mit China da ist er
eng an der Seite mit himbing es ging
aber auch darum dass er mit Erdogan
gesprochen hat dem türkischen
Präsidenten dem indischen premiermodi
jetzt hören wir jetzt sagen auch sie das
mag so sein die wegbewegung Chinas von
Russland das sind sozusagen die
Anzeichen wenn das so kommen sollte
wer bleibt denn dann noch als
Verbündeter Putins
ich glaube was von vor allen Dingen in
den Bildern sehen konnte ist bei solchen
Treffen gibt es immer ganz viele
bilaterale Gespräch das wird doch jetzt
bei den G20-Treffen zu sein auch in dem
Treffen der
operationsorganisation war es schon so
dass offensichtlich einige Akteure
insgesamt aus China Russland
signalisiert haben dass es auf einem
falschen Weg ist und dass man nicht
möchte dass dieser Weg fortgesetzt wird
also diese Isolation ist nicht versetzen
Bali das erste Mal auftaucht sondern was
schon lange dort angefangen hat für
Russland werden die Partner in der Tat
weniger oder der Bereich in dem man
kooperieren kann wird immer weniger den
Russland das muss man ja Aussehen aus
der Ostner Sicht von China brauchen sich
das Westens hat zwar eine geopolitische
Lage die interessant ist die relevant
ist sind aber als Bedeutung als Markt
insbesondere für zum Beispiel
chinesische Produkte waren Produkte
einfach ab das heißt also für China ist
auch die ökonomische Dimension Russlands
immer weniger bedeutsam interessant ist
aber das Russland lange Zeit lang nicht
immer dazu sagen ein politisch
militärische ökonomisch Kräfte in Europa
binden wird weil jetzt natürlich im
Wesentlichen erstmal darauf gucken wie
wird sich Russland in Zukunft verhalten
und das hemmt natürlich die Verteilung
der Ressourcen die die USA sehr gerne
von Europa hätte nämlich dass wir die
USA viel stärker mit Blick auf Asien und
China unterstützen will also wir sehen
es schält sich immer stärker ein Dreieck
heraus
in dem Moskau sicherlich schwächer wird
aber auch diese Schwäche kann dazu
führen dass irgendjemand diesen Dreieck
wiederum stärker wird
was glauben Sie wie wird sich dieses
Dreieck in den kommenden Wochen Monaten
weiterentwickeln kann man das schon
prognostizieren
das kann man und man liegt damit
garantiert falsch deswegen will ich das
jetzt keinen Fall machen wir haben ja
gesehen wie
wie sprunghaft die kriegsverläufe sind
und es hängt in erheblichen Maßen davon
ab wie dieser Krieg zu Ende Gedicht wann
sollen wir zu Ende geht was tatsächlich
an politischer Macht und auch ein
militärischer Macht in Moskau
tatsächlich verbleiben kann das muss man
glaube ich so klar sehen man kann sich
ganz unterschiedliches Szenarien
vorstellen das eine ist die Möglichkeit
dass es tatsächlich einen
einen Waffenstillstand geht ich will
nicht von einem Frieden sprechen der
länger dauert und belastbarer ist als
die letzten die wir gehabt haben mit
Moskau also die Ukraine mit Moskau
gehabt hat es kann aber auch sein dass
es zu Nachfolge kämpfenden Moskau gibt
es sozusagen das komplett andere Extrem
das ist zum nachfolgekämpfen in Moskau
geht um die Position des Präsidenten und
man damit eine große Instabilität und
bis hin zu einer teilweisen Stillstand
oder ein Zusammenbrechen der staatlichen
Funktion
möglicherweise ich denke also sie sehen
da ist viel Spiel drin deswegen ist es
sehr schwierig da jetzt oder sehr gewagt
da eine steile These nach vorne zu
stellen ja absolut sehr viel Dynamik
auch drin bleiben wir bei einem Aspekt
von denen sie sagen dass sie es für
unwahrscheinlich halten oder auch nicht
sagen wollen dass man jetzt direkt von
einem Frieden sprechen kann Präsident
selenski hat ja heute noch mal in der
Region betont wir sind bereit für
Frieden aber für einen Frieden unter
unseren Bedingungen unsere
Korrespondentin Moskau hat gesagt dass
da auch schon das Fete und Dementi
prompt aus Moskau gefolgt ist also mich
würde aber trotzdem noch mal ihre
Erklärung interessieren warum sie das
friedensszenario als unwahrscheinlich
einschätzen
naja wir haben zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
eigentlich aus der ukrainischen Sicht
keinen Grund in Verhandlung einzustimmen
weil man militärisch noch im
in der Offensive ist und man tatsächlich
noch Räume gewinnen kann wir erinnern
uns zurück vor zwei Wochen hätte man vor
zwei Wochen verhandelt und wir sollten
immer fahren oder die Ukraine sollte
immer verhandeln dann wirkt ja schon
nicht befreit worden so das wäre
vielleicht Teil eines begreements
geworden oder auch nicht dann hätte
tatsächlich dann wäre diese diese Gegend
nicht befreit worden noch ist die
Ukraine in der Lage Land zurück zu
gewinnen das heißt aus deren Sicht macht
es halt keinen Sinn zu verhandeln und
der wichtigste Punkt ist es gibt relativ
wenig Hoffnung dass was auch immer als
Verhandlungsergebnis beim waffenstillen
rauskäme das belastbar wäre denn diesen
waffenschüssel hat es ja schon gegeben
wir haben 2014 eine Waffenstillstand
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland gehabt
der ist aber immer wieder gebrochen
worden es sind mehr Menschen gestorben
innerhalb in der Zeit des
waffenschillstands als vor dieser
auseinander als vor dem als vor dem
Waffenstillstand das heißt das Vertrauen
in Moskau dass ein solcher Vertrag
eingehalten wird und nicht dazu genutzt
wird um einfach eine Zeit zu gewinnen um
seine militärischen Kräfte wieder
aufzubauen dieses Vertrauen ist im
besten Falle gering wenn gar nicht
vorhanden es gibt auch keinen Grund
dieses Vertrauen zu haben
da kommt auch eine passende user-frage
rein von Tom Pist Trub bei Youtube er
geht auch in dieselbe Richtung und sagt
bei Friedensverhandlungen kommen niemals
die Maximalforderung einer Seite raus
außer es wird eine Kapitulation
erzwungen wie sieht das ist seine Frage
ein Kompromiss aus ihrer Sicht aus
eine zu schwer zu skizzieren der
Kompromiss bedeutet ja dass beide Seiten
sich auch etwas verständigen können was
sie dann auch wovon sie auch glauben
dass jeweils der andere ist einhält das
ist glaube ich der Kompromiss unter
Kompromiss muss jeweils zu Hause
vertretbar sein auch das gehört mit dazu
ich muss das zu Hause meinen meinen
Menschen erklären können dass ich diesen
Kompromiss eingegangen bin und wir haben
hier gerade deswegen einen Krieg weil
wir und weil es um etwas geht was nicht
verhandelbar oder was nicht teilbar ist
nämlich ein Gebiet und die Menschen die
darauf wohnen von daher sehe ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nur sehr schwer einen
kompromissing zumindest keinen
Kompromiss der bedeuten würde
dass die Ukraine Territorium abgibt aber
das muss man noch mal ganz klar sagen
hängt von der Lage auf dem Gefechtsfeld
ab die Verhandlungsbereitschaft der
beiden Akteure sowohl Moskau als auch
hier verändert sich immer wieder in
Abhängigkeit von der militärischen Lage
das heißt das Militär das politische
spielen immer wieder zusammen das heißt
auch das Verhandlungen und das Führen
von Krieg nicht getrennt voneinander zu
sehen sind sondern sie bedingen sich
gegenseitig
bleiben wir dann ganz kurz bei der
militärischen Lage auch wenn die
Prognose immer schwierig ist aber was
sind ihre aktuellen Informationen
darüber was man erahnen kann wie sich
die militärische Lage in den kommenden
Wintermonaten entwickeln wird also
nachdem die
ukrainepro vorgedrungen ist wird ja
jetzt vor allem im Osten gekämpft aber
was glauben Sie wie wird das jetzt in
den kommenden Wintermonaten weitergehen
also die Ukraine hat militärisch und
politisch gute Gründe diesen Krieg auf
alle Fälle weiterzuführen wir haben ja
zurzeit auch relativ viel Diskussionen
darum dass der Winter diesen Krieg zum
Stillstand bringen würde ich glaube
nicht dass das passiert warum nicht weil
man auf der einen Seite militärisch
jetzt noch sozusagen den den Impuls
nutzen kann man hat auch die
Unterstützung zu Hause es ist also
möglich weiter zu kämpfen es ist
wahrscheinlich auch notwendig weiter zu
kämpfen denn wenn die Diskussionen über
diesen Krieg weitergehen sowie zur Zeit
und wenn wir wieder viel Diskussion über
Verhandlungen haben und dass man doch im
Winter nicht kämpfen kann und dass man
auch im Grunde genommen jetzt den Krieg
ich glaube militärische auch politisch
einfrieren müsste und die Ukraine wird
sich dringend bemüht sehen gegen diese
Ideen die dann bei uns in den Medien
zirkulieren andere Bilder zu senden das
heißt also Bilder davon dass der Krieg
weitergeht damit diese Diskussion
eigentlich keinen empirische Grundlage
hat das heißt es gibt militärische
Gründe als auch politische grün für Kiew
weiter zu kämpfen um Gelände weiterhin
zu gewinnen um Moskau auch keine
Atempause zu zu gestehen denn ansonsten
könnte Moskau sich neu formieren aber
auch politisch mit Blick auf die
Unterstützung des Westens die
wahrscheinlich zurückgehen würde oder
aber zum Schluss dann kommen würde wenn
es keine positiven Meldungen mehr über
den Fortgang des Krieges in der Ukraine
geben würde danke Ihnen für diese
Einschätzung zwei Aspekte zum Abschluss
unseres Gesprächs einer der geht etwas
zurück aber es ist eine user-frage die
ich Ihnen natürlich nicht vorenthalten
möchte die geht noch mal auf das Dreieck
was Sie beschrieben haben ein in Bezug
auf USA China und Russland die Frage
kommt von will Erys bei Youtube er fragt
wo ist Europa in diesem Dreieck
bestimmt Europa habe ich jetzt an dem
Punkt rausgelassen weil es sozusagen
dieses Spannungsverhältnis Europa spielt
natürlich eine Rolle in den Zusammenhang
wir sind ein enger Partner der USA wir
sind aber nicht die USA
aber wir sehen ja schon dass in dem was
ich hier gerade raus bildet nämlich
tatsächlich eine eine systemische
Konfrontation also eine Konfrontation
zwischen politischen Systemen und damit
auch weltanschaulichen Systemen aber
auch eine
Konfrontation auf unterschiedlichen
Politikfelder oder Problemfälle also die
Ökonomie das militärische aber auch das
politische dass da Europa eine
wesentliche Rolle spielt und den USA
sicherlich deutlich näher steht als
China oder Russland das heißt also ja
man kann dieses Dreieck auch zu einem
Viereck machen und dann spielt Europa
darin eine Rolle das ist ein sehr
einfaches Bild was ich hier benutzt habe
also von daher da gehört Europa
sicherlich mit rein ich würde es
allerdings nicht so einfach und
wunderbar wieder in einen alten
westentransferieren weil das sicherlich
eine eine Rhetorik aus der Vergangenheit
ich glaube das Europa dass das
Verhältnis das französische Verhältnis
sich in den nächsten Jahren einfach noch
neu definieren wird auch abhängig davon
wer in den USA aber auch in Europa in
den nächsten Jahren eine Touren gibt
und unsere Userinnen und User sie
kommentieren fleißig weiter und stellen
noch eine interessante Frage von hoher
bei Youtube geht jetzt wieder in Bezug
auf dem militärischen Kriegsverlauf und
auch auf den Blick aufs Ende was müsste
sich da Fraktur für Russland signifikant
ändern damit man ein Ende des Kriegs aus
deren sich zumindest für günstiger
halten kann
ja das kann man jetzt sag mal
theoretisch oder generisch beantworten
die Kosten die eine spätere
Verhandlungslösung bedeutet die müssten
deutlich höher sein als sie jetzigen
Kosten zu jetzigen Zeitpunkt es ist so
dass Putin ein schlecht geführter Krieg
immer noch mehr hilft als ein schlechter
Frieden das ist bitter das ist aber so
warum
ich finde es ganz einfach versuchen in
dem Augenblick indem sie sagen okay wir
machen jetzt einen Waffenstillstand dann
ist im Grunde um so etwas wie Tag der
Abrechnung oder Zahltag dann wird
geguckt was hat denn jeder eigentlich
und da steht hier eigentlich zur
Verhandlung und in dem Augenblick würde
deutlich werden dass Moskau sein Blatt
komplett überreizt hat man hat diese
vier Gebiete annektiert die jetzt
eigentlich formal aus russischer Sicht
russisches Gebiet sind man verliert aber
jeden Tag Boden auf diesem Gebieten das
heißt also das politische Überleben des
Präsidenten würde in dem Augenblick in
dem Zahltag wäre wahrscheinlich deutlich
unwahrscheinlicher sein dass er das
überlebt
als das als wenn er diesen Krieg einfach
am Laufen hält und wir sehen dass das
russische Regime dynisch ist gegenüber
Menschen das ist bereit ist jederzeit zu
lügen und es bereitet Menschen
tausendfach auch wenn sie schlecht
ausgebildet sind in den Krieg zu
schicken was ich damit meine sind die
die Soldatinnen Soldaten die
teilmobilisiert worden sind das heißt
also hier ist nicht damit zu rechnen
dass in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein
Frieden zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
tatsächlich für Moskau interessant ist
auf der anderen Seite wird Kiew
wahrscheinlich viel von dem was es an
jetzt an Gebieten gewonnen hat nicht
einfach so wieder abgeben auch Kiew hat
gezeigt dass es militärisch nicht
einfach zu besiegen ist
danke dafür für ihre Einordnungen zu
diesem menschenverachten russischen
Angriffskrieg und auch den Erklärungen
mit Blick auf die Szenarien eine
Abschlussfrage die bezieht sich von mir
noch mal auf den G20-Gipfel in den
kommenden Tagen das Treffen heute einen
Tag vor dem offiziellen Start zwischen
he und beiden was erwarten sie aber vom
G20 Gipfel generell
ich glaube der G20 Gipfel ist die
Möglichkeit
höher insbesondere für den für den
Bundeskanzler
zu gucken in welche Richtung er ganz
gerne das deutsche Netzwerk die
deutschen Verbindungen eigentlich
spannen will er war gerade zuvor in
Peking hat auch vor seiner Reise klar
gemacht dass er die Abhängigkeiten die
Deutschland hat diversifizieren will
also es geht nicht darum Deutschland
abzukappen sondern aber diese strenge
die man hat im Grunde über viele
unterschiedliche Schultern zu verteilen
so dass man nicht von einem Akteur so
stark abhängig ist wie wir das zurzeit
von Russland sind aber auch von China
sind und ich glaube das ist eine der
vielen Möglichkeiten ist der
Bundeskanzler nutzen wird um tatsächlich
dieses Netzwerk weiter zu spinnen das
zeigt ja auch dass diese Reise die er in
die Region macht die macht ja nicht nur
die 20 gibt sie jetzt ja schon genutzt
um in der Region klar zu machen ist für
mehr und neue Kooperationen
Wirtschaftsbereich und ich erwarte dass
das tatsächlich etwas ist wo man einen
weiteren Baustein in dem Umbau der
deutschen Außenwirtschaftspolitik sehen
wird Erwartungen und Aussagen von
Christian Mölling Politikwissenschaftler
und Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik in
Berlin vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit hier
bei zettchen
ganz herzlichen Dank auch an euch fürs
mitdiskutieren fürs Kommentare schreiben
fürs Fragen reinstellen zu unserem Thema
vielen Dank dass ihr heute dabei gewesen
seid und wir werden diese Situation rund
um den G20 Gipfel natürlich auf allen
Kanälen des ZDF sowohl im Fernsehen in
der App oder hier auch bei ZDF heute
live weiter im Blick behalten ihr werdet
weiter von uns informiert werden und wir
würden uns freuen wenn wir beim nächsten
Mal wieder bei uns am Start seid tschüss